we had we had to vet men more because we  could possibly get pregnant because  birth control is a Fail-Safe right if  you get if you get an IUD you have like  a 99 chance of not getting pregnant okay  so that's a Fail-Safe and if that  doesn't work you can get an abortion but  and so they we had to prioritize a man  that was going to stick around okay and  typically like we got married younger  and the men around us vetted the men  around us like our fathers would vet  guys before we would go on dates with  them and stuff and like women we're kind  of dumb like a guy can sweet talk us and  like yeah  like we're not you know because you know  it's true right and so but men vet men  better because they can tell you when  someone's like talking [ __ ] to you